hello everyone Karen Morton with film
courage the radio show were outside the
studio with Dennis Peters and Ross
Pruden and we just had a great interview
with Jamie King and we're talking about
Votto net and bit torrenting and we had
one question that we left on the table
and that pertains to on the movie tilt
by Phil Holbrook and written by Julie
Keck and Jessica King and we're
wondering what would your approach be
with tilt the movie would you try and
get it out there on a bit torrenting
site would you try and retain that you
know structure and keep it on a site and
sell it from there and make sure that no
one else had access to it what would be
your method well I guess the first thing
would be is what are the goals for sale
and Julie and Jessica do they want to
use this as a stepping stone to the next
film do they have investors who are
expecting a return on this film so those
are those are a couple of things that we
would we would need to think about ahead
of time since I don't know the answer
that I'll sort of jump in as the I you
know for me the real value of the
pirating is as a marketing tool to get
the therm out there and spread the word
if you don't have a large marketing
budget or some cases any marketing
budget you have your twitter followers
your facebook fans it's fairly limited
so let's put that out and have people
you don't know begin to share the film
and that way it spreads now how do you
make any money from that we've had so
many discussions and I'll also talk
about this way more than I will but
there isn't any proof necessarily that
says people who are watching yourself
for free well then go buy it so I think
that's a fallacy to think you've watched
it for free how many times have you
watched the same movie if I have a movie
I have three copies of the big lebowski
has he changed some things like you had
why I watch comes over and over about by
different copies of it so I don't think
that's necessarily
a thing that if it's for free so i would
use photo done it as a marketing tool to
spread the word that's how i would start
okay sighs it must be my kid so yeah I
mean I i agree i think that you really
have to know what the goals are
immediately is it that you have people
you have to pay back is there some sort
of capital a capital that needs to be
recouped or is it I really shut this
thing for next to nothing and all I need
to do is get the visibility but really I
mean my feeling is that the trend and
you know I'm thinking it 10 years out 5
10 15 years out the trend is going to be
towards free access to content and
having a buffet of content like Netflix
where people pay one price and they are
able to get any film that they ever want
to watch and if that isn't offered that
it's going to be offered by de facto
pirating website people are no people
already have access to almost any film
out there that they want to see so the
question about how to make money off of
it is I think it presupposes that the
movie is the thing what you're selling
and I think it's now we're seeing that
that's putting the cart before the horse
because yes the you've made this product
but what is the inherent nature of that
product and that product is copyable
over and over and over again with or
without restrictions someone is going to
copy the phone someone is going to
release it so how do you make money off
of something which is infinitely
releasable infinitely distributable if
you want and the example that i love to
go back to is steam steam is a as a
network for games for for PC gamers and
anybody can get any game that they want
for free and some sort of parted website
but people still use steam they prefer
to use staying because steam offers a
lot of things that you
yet with pirated software it offers you
the convenience of fantastic catalog of
games immediate so that the game
downloads immediately to your computer
it's usually very inexpensive they have
lots of sales for games that maybe the
game is priced at ten dollars but then
they do these fire sales every these
weekend deals where the games are two
dollars so you've got a massive number
of people just buying a game immediately
now I think that that same model can
work because it also it makes it seem
allows you to talk to other people on
their network so if a friend of mine
also uses steam if I'm in game and he's
in game he I can see that he's going
into a different game oh my great let's
play together so games are cooperative
things that works well for games and may
not work quite as well for movies but I
think that how to monetize it is steam
adds value to 2 games which are infinite
there an infinitely distributable
product but if you add value to that add
a scarce element like convenience like
immediacy like belonging like community
like all these things that only the
network can offer you only this added
value can offer then you start making my
and steam has been enormously successful
doing this so I don't see that there's
any reason why someone like Ben hex like
that last week I thought that was a
great post because he his logical
conclusion was you know either we can
all be individuals you know trying to
sell our movies or we can bend together
pool our resources and effectively do
that same thing but with a group of
films and we have more bargaining power
that's genius i think that that is the
direction that it's going and i think
that you are already starting to see
things like mu B and other collectives
coming together to do that so and then
if that really answers your question
well i'm going to i love reading your
stuff brian and it's very forward
thinking I'm going to go back to the
specific I think a lot of people I'm
going to use my phone I think many be
business they go to see a film made by a
filmmaker so it could be an actor
director so why do I want to go see that
film could be the subject matter as well
but it's often the person so one thing
that Phil might be able to do with this
Sonnen just suppose it is do Julian jazz
is to use this to create their
reputation so get as big of an honest as
you can to watch this no use that as a
stepping stone for lectures perhaps
around the subject matter at the subject
matter of does that nagging oh they're
doing some great stuff with their
marketing already so they've got a big
head start on the social media part of
this the tilt to the town it's brilliant
so they have things already in place
that could be viral use use this
marketing to build brand reputation so
that when film does is exhales like I
want to see if Phil Holbrook fell me I
want to see stay on cooter offended
because in this sea of conservative
leader in the last five years or 50,000
indie films how do you use stand down
how does your film stand out and it
stands out as hang I'm going to search
for your film I one looking for Phil
Holbrook film as opposed to what might I
find today so I think that's one of the
things that that that I hate the word
pirating but I guess you know putting a
puppy repair can do is is you know
create that buzz around you as a
filmmaker and and so that would be one
valuable thing build your brand
reputation and build a brand around
yourself and now you're selling that
which is what you're mentioning is well
so you're not necessarily only selling
your phone you're selling a bigger
experience discover what that
experiences he what he may be able to
monetize it tilt the town mm-hmm that
may be the thing that drives revenue
think of it that II shirts lots of
t-shirts in Chicago that would even in
terms of how till the town could end up
being something you know like Farmville
I mean who knows where that might go and
and think you think that way you know
and use the film to launch other things
say Kevin Smith has already done this
he's he's movies using red state to tour
around the country
and he already he's already very
talkative persons yet i'm going to enjoy
because that's the problem he's inverted
if you're famous and do it it's
different yeah well he has a larger
scale his comes across pens it's more
expensive with his he built his fan base
the traditional way yeah through miramax
films yeah yeah sure but but but that's
not entirely legitimate because his fan
base loves him they love to interact
with him no I see the quote yeah yes
over and in fact they do a fantastic job
of reaching out to their faculties
they're always really funny I love
talking to his people they're just great
and I think that that's a key part to
building fans and getting patronage I
think that's absolutely right it's like
you know they do a great job this and I
just want to support them because
they're so great not even necessarily
because their content is great the
content may not be I don't know but I
like them and I like you there are like
what they stand for and I think we see
that over and over and over again people
are willing to be patrons despite all
else it's really amazing and if Phil can
create something around his going back
to specific of the marketing of his
fellow there found is is there something
and maybe using tellin down to create an
event for the screening of the film so
maybe you're bringing together people
from tilt the town or you're having it
you know you've created the virtual now
we're in of the real world whatever that
might be create an event around the fell
for screenings yeah which is what Kevin
Smith has done he's going he's you know
sixty dollars of taken or whatever to
watch his phone right now it's but he's
Kevin stuff but so maybe maybe Phil
could do something like that and that
will help for this about the work you
know get it get that out create an event
which we've all talked about before yeah
because the event cannot be parked it if
it is you're not you fired and that's
where you might make money and people
say he feels going to be there doing
Jess are going to be there I wouldn't
get this and be part of that and I'm
going to pay forty dollars or I'm going
to go to that it's going to be a fun
night and that may be the way that
revenue can be generated
I could easily see them doing a film to
her with it in fact doing a film tour to
all the like all the all the locations
other locations and then having those
people who have supported them until to
town support them more and getting a
local venue to to screen with us I told
me I told you we would solve the problem
we have peer-to-peer solve and they done
Phil 10 upsetting only ten percent we're
even better than some of the other side
yeah we're free